oh hi everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel today's video is sponsored by
harmonix who you probably know is the
people who made rock band
and dance central today i'm playing fuza
this is a game that's supposed to be
like a non-stop music festival where you
control the music
i'm into it let's do it i don't even
like campaign i guess oh there is
multiplayer and then i guess you can
share mixes on social
anyway let's go
okay yeah first show ever seems good
seems like a good option let's do it
all right
you hear that yes that's the sound of a
thousand of my most die-hard superpowers
i thought it was bass
my apologies
amazing i don't know why you're yelling
it's just the two of us
and i'll be back here talking to you
through your headset the whole time
okay i'll let you know what the crowd
wants and how to keep the party
going all right i'm ready for whatever
this is going to be i genuinely have no
idea
[Laughter]
i don't know what i'm walking into i
feel very unprepared
that's cool damn no okay we'll keep it
simple just start the set
nobody needs to stress about it i bet
you'll be playing headliners
maybe even teammates tk sunshine let's
not get ahead okay
[Music]
all right got it
oh okay got it
now let's add something okay
i understand you're just taking elements
from the different songs smashing them
together
wait for the right time though game's
not telling me to but i want to
fill things out got it
can do bro put some ghastly in here
give it a second give it a second
[Music]
now add some vocals
i'm gonna go gambino cause he's my boy
didn't love the way that started but
it's okay
[Music]
uh okay more rick astley's in here
and we're gonna let me use it twice
[Music]
i'm all right i'm cool with it yeah it
uh is worth noting these
super recognizable songs right
um i know it has like florida billy
eilish features songs from artists you
know
[Music]
gotta get the right time again
[Music]
i should have done it off to the next
count
okay okay i'm all right with it thank
you
i appreciate it we have multiple pop
discs yeah we got that
okay just enjoy my work here
i do want to throw this in the let's do
it let's do it
[Music]
it's a good song it's a good song it
slaps still
always
oh okay we have to add more poppin
this is gonna be this guppy pop over
here
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
it's pretty cool it's intuitive i feel
like it probably gets a lot more
complicated the more you play
um can confirm nothing like djing which
is also okay
[Music]
yes can't confirm oh i was already doing
that
[Music]
this is a good song
[Music]
okay
ooh slightly light okay
uh cause i try to do the same one i'm
gonna fix that all right let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
all right really mixing stuff up here
sounds interesting
[Music]
i should have i should have done it
already but i got nervous what could i
do
i think i want to do satisfaction vocals
let's do that okay so we're going to
swap this out first
[Music]
wait son of a bite
[Music]
all right you gotta wait for the right
time to get rid of the gambino which i
never want to do but it has been playing
for a while
i would have thought that was on time
okay i just need to press it tiny bit
earlier
video games got a video game
but i have to change them again okay
let's go sweep it a psycho then
[Music]
okay feeling it feeling it
[Music]
it wasn't late i disagree oh let's do
this
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
there we go it is just earlier than i
think it is
[Music]
i can do whatever i want here okay
i already have this plane somewhere no i
swapped it out
oh that's already okay what do you mean
so close
what did i do wrong oh it was time
i wasn't paying attention to that got it
i didn't do the task in the timer i see
i see i see i missed it
what a banger just what an ongoing bag
[Music]
[Music]
it's not that great
that was actually not the right place in
that song to mix anything in for the
record
but if that's what they want then that's
what they want
that was the right time
have i not used anything i don't know
about this hot stuff yet
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right i'm really just making me mix
things up here huh
[Music]
i'm getting too nervous
[Music]
because i'm trying to do it like i
normally would and i have to train my
brain out of it you know
[Applause]
because that's not the right place to do
it i got the achievement but that's a
terrible place to cut
the audio between the songs that's i
made it was the wrong thing to do
people don't know what they want is what
i'm telling you
[Music]
this seems like it's going to have the
most space which is why i want it
um yeah this song used to play it like
an office i worked at all the time
well it was in eb games so it just
burned into my brain
[Music]
damn it i really stress myself out you
just the time is and just
almost have to pay attention to which
i'm into actually we like paying
attention to things
for the record punch my microphone
trying to grab a drink
is some montage of people being happy
with me how did i do i feel like i did
okay
85 percent of goals i could have done
better room for improvement there
that's fair that's fair all right bad
for your first show
it's gonna get more rewarding and more
challenging from here
clearly i got a beat stuck in my head um
yeah so i do need to tell you guys the
game is coming out
on the 10th of november before i forget
read voice time
coming on november 10th pre-order fuse
it about yourself three
bonus tracks i will have a pre-order
link in the description below because
with fuser
anyone can be a dj discover what's in
your dj dna and take the test at
djdnatest.com
to get your own unique dj profile is
that good did i do it
i just want to check out the multiplayer
before i tap out here of these
no i can watch a freestyle show
i wonder if someone else is even playing
right now surely they're not
surely that's not a thing it's on a
private show join a freestyle show
again i feel like matchmaking's not
gonna work but that's actually a really
cool feature
that you have you can just
what a great thing to have during cover
you could just broadcast this to people
yeah okay so there are no active shows
obviously this is pre-release build as
it says on the screen
uh it's probably not gonna work for me
which i understand makes sense
uh but that's it for me today everyone
for the most part it seems like it's
super cool let's
i love uh any of these kind of rhythm
games and this one is an interesting
extension of what harmonix has already
done that i know a lot of people have
been pretty excited about so
cool to check it out hopefully next time
i do a better job
uh link in the description to where you
can pre-order is below i'm alana i will
see you guys next time
bye